zehntausende infizierte bald 2000
menschen die an dem corona virus
gestorben sind alle prognosen sind
eingetreten also es war keine panikmache
einfaches logisches denken hätte genug
zum schluss zufolge wie sich das corona
virus ausbreitet doch wie geht es jetzt
weiter
klicks um science fiction die gibt's
täglich spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal und aktivierte
glocke nur dann verpasst ihr nichts
herzlich willkommen die seriöse
fachleute die die schnelle weltweite
ausbreitung des neuartigen corona virus
saß kopf 2 für unwahrscheinlich gehalten
haben
schon deswegen war die bisherige
entwicklung absehbar und die zukünftige
ist es auch inzwischen hat sich auch das
robert koch institut aus berlin zu wort
gemeldet und kann nach eigener aussage
eine pandemie nicht mehr ausschließen
inzwischen gibt es außerhalb von china
mehr als 700 infizierter allein auf dem
kreuzfahrtschiff diamond princess das im
hafen von yokohama in japan unter
quarantäne steht sind 355 menschen
infiziert rund 1200 passagierinnen
wurden getestet das heißt ein viertel
ist er krank von den getesteten allein
das belegt die hohe ansteckungsgefahr
des virus und es belegt welcher aufwand
getrieben werden muss und in china
betrieben wird damit die ausbreitung der
krankheit cupid 19 wird sie genannt
gebremst wird und in china sehen wir wie
schnell sich die krankheit trotzdem
ausbreitet rund 70.000 infizierte rund
1600 menschen sind an der infektion
gestorben rund 10.000 sind inzwischen
symptomfrei und wieder gesund all das
kann man auf die gesamte erde
hochrechnen und ein fakt beunruhigt alle
fachleute die krankheit kommt wie eine
leichte erkältung daher und verbreitet
sich offenbar sogar noch schneller was
auch daran liegt dass man nur ganz
leichte symptome zu haben braucht oder
auch fast gar keine um die krankheit zu
verbreiten das virus vermehrt sich schon
im rachen und darauf kann kein
gesundheitssystem vorbereitet sein
selbst in deutschland könnte es viel
mehr infizierte geben als bekannt dazu
der epidemiologe gérard krause im
spiegel das wäre denkbar
unter dem radar des gesundheitssystems
auch in deutschland kleineren begrenzte
cluster existieren die nicht weiter
auffallen
und die können die infektion dann
unerkannt verbreiten aber noch schlimmer
wäre das auf einem kontinent wie afrika
hier ist bisher eine einzige infektion
entdeckt worden
ich hatte hier ja schon vor einiger zeit
das gefährliche potenzial in afrika
beschrieben inzwischen haben auch
forschende diese gefahr benannt zum
einen ist es extrem seltsam dass es dort
bis jetzt nur einen menschen gibt der
infiziert ist und das obwohl zwischen
china und afrika reger reiseverkehr
herrscht china hat dort milliarden
investiert und allein in wohin also da
wo die infektion ausgebrochen ist
studieren 500 afrikaner innen spricht
die gefahr durch ein solches cluster
weltweit ist immens wenn es nicht
deutschland ist dann ist es vielleicht
irgendein land in afrika bill gates
gründer von microsoft und jetzt mit
seiner frau kopf der melinda und bill
gates stiftung befürchtet schlimmes
zitat es gibt viel was wir nicht über
diese epidemie wissen aber es gibt auch
viel was wir wissen das zeigt dass sie
sehr dramatisch werden könnte besonders
wenn sie sich in gegenden wie dem
südlichen afrika oder dem südlichen
asien ausbreitet 100 millionen dollar
umgerechnet 92 millionen euro wird die
stiftung von seiner frau und ihm zur
bekämpfung der epidemie und für die
entwicklung eines impfstoffs
bereitstellen es spricht leider alles
dafür dass sich die verbreitung nicht
mehr aufhalten lässt experten hoffen
jetzt dass die schnelle ausbreitung aber
zumindest möglichst lange hinausgezögert
wird zwar stehen die chancen laut
fachleuten schlecht dass noch vor dem
beginn der pandemie ein impfstoff
gefunden wird aber vielleicht findet
sich schon vorher ein medikament werden
ja über eine künstliche intelligenz
berichtet die vielleicht einen wirkstoff
gefunden hat und auch wenn es hier in
deutschland neben den 16 infizierten
noch mehr menschen geben sollte die
infiziert wären die wahrscheinlichkeit
hier in deutschland angesteckt zu werden
ist statistisch gesehen nahezu null erst
wenn die epidemie in einem land
ausbricht das dem ausbruch nicht herr
wird und die infektion in der folge über
die erde schwappt dann sollten wir uns
hier sorgen machen und dann kann es auch
hier zu erheblichen folgen führen weil
es wahrscheinlich nicht vermeidbar sein
wird dass sich jeder an steckt niemand
hat antikörper gegen das virus lars koch
das wird also wahrscheinlich passieren
aber nicht heute die fast also sehr real
aber noch nicht hier in europa
angekommen auch wenn hier schon ein
infizierter gestorben ist das ein
80-jähriger mann der aus china
eingereist war und durch den erreger
eine schwere lungenentzündung bekommen
hat und das ist auch noch ein wichtiger
punkt wenn eine pandemie ausbricht
müssen sich vor allem männer über 60 mit
einer vorerkrankung sorgen machen noch
soll kein einziges kind an dem corona
virus gestorben sein
wir haben eine playlist mit allen
wichtigen infos zu infektionen
zusammengestellt dafür hier klicken und
wir freuen uns über jede unterstützung
für unsere täglichen videos werden gerne
kanal mitglieder bekommt ihr die videos
auch früher vor allen anderen das geht
hier unten unter dem video oder auf der
kanalseite also draufklicken angucken
abonnieren klicks und science fiction
bis dann bleibt dran